mission impossible fallout is quite
possibly the most spectacular entry in
the series so far on top of another
round of insanely awesome action
sequences this sixth installment also
connects deeply to the past five movies
in the franchise yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers it's Jan here and today I'm
explaining all the connections between
Fallout characters and plot and the
other Mission Impossible movies Plus how
the ending sets up a seventh film I'll
be talking white widow Ilsa Faust
Julia's return Henry Cavill Solomon Lane
the new mi7 team and Easter eggs of
course spoilers ahead if you've not seen
the movie yet the end of Mission
Impossible fallout sees the newly
recaptured Solomon Lane handed over to
British intelligence by the CIA taking
care of that transaction is the white
widow whose CIA boss Erica Sloane refers
to us the broker white widow is actually
the daughter of max the arms dealer from
the very first movie and it appears that
she's in charge of the same dubious
organization that max led and the
ongoing arrangement that CIA boss Sloan
mentions as Lane is handed over is a
reference to the deal that max was
forced to make at the end of the first
mission impossible when she was caught
and arrested on the train by the CIA it
looks like white widow will be a
returning player in future Mission
Impossible movies which could be
interesting given her organization's
nefarious connections in the underworld
I also noticed the Ethan and white
widows relationship in Fallout 2 mirrors
Ethan's story with max in the first film
in fallout Ethan pretends to be lark in
order to meet the white widow just like
he pretended to be job to meet max in
the first movie and fallout even plays
up some flirtation between Ethan and
White Widow similar to that hinted at
between Max and Ethan I also thought it
was incredible how Vanessa Kirby who
plays White Widow sounded so similar to
Vanessa redgraves max even channeling a
number of her mannerisms also in
fallouts final scene is a big hint to
rebecca Ferguson's future in the
franchise when sloane explains that the
CIA's transaction with mi6 closes their
friends account with British
intelligence earlier Ilsa told Ethan she
was being forced to continue working
with the British Secret Service in order
to prove she wasn't a rogue agent
however now that ilss is free and clear
of mi6 she'll be available to become a
member of the IMF by the end of fallout
it also has also been confirmed as
Ethan's love interest going forward with
the movie having developed the
relationship between them showing they
do actually care for each other even if
Ethan does run her over with a car there
is of course the master of michelle
monaghan julia who returns for a small
but significant role she and Ethan
opened the movie in a callback to their
wedding scene in Mission Impossible 3
this distorted nightmare-like sequence
has Solomon Lane officiating at the
wedding and he begins to taunt Ethan
about his lies to Julia and leading a
double life blaming Ethan for her
abduction in mi3 the subsequent
separation and how she had to go into
hiding for her own safety in the fourth
film this scenes important because it
sets up Ethan state of mind and fall out
where he's troubled by visions of losing
his moral compass and harming or killing
innocent people in the course of his
missions the other purpose of this scene
is to set up Julia's reintroduction
later in the movie something which Tom
Cruise had specifically requested I
asked Tom what's the one thing you want
to do and he said people are still
asking me about Julia you know you can't
be with Ilsa they're still Julia and he
said I want to tie up that story so I
said okay we can do that but we have to
do it in a way that it's not something
we're just kind of cut out of the movie
it has to really be baked into the
narrative it's nice to see Michelle
Monaghan back and properly integrated
into the story after her tiny cameo in
the fourth film her scene with Luther
catches us up on what she's been doing
since her split from Ethan and she has a
tender reunion with her ex-husband at
the very end where they come to terms
with why they have to be a part I think
Julia's story is likely wrapped up now
in the franchise however she could
always return if the story warranted it
for example we don't really know who her
new husband is exactly so there's always
a chance he could turn out to be one of
lanes apostles also interestingly at the
end of the movie Ilsa whispers something
into Julia's ear although Ilsa's was on
to audible it does show a connection
between the two who are to quote Luther
the only two women Ethan has ever been
serious about and maybe Ethan himself
knows what Ilsa said given what a good
lip reader we saw he was in Mission
Impossible 3 but let me know if you've
got any theories on what you think she
said to Julia similar to Alec Baldwin's
Hunley
rogue nation Angela Bassett Erica Sloane
progresses from an adversarial view of
the IMF at the start of the movie to a
positive view of the team by the end
with hon Lee's death in Fallout I think
the film heavily hinted that Sloane will
become the new secretary for Mission
Impossible 7 still alive at the end of
fallout is Solomon Lane he could return
as it's quite possible there are other
apostles out there who splintered off
from the syndicate and are ready to take
up arms indeed the original TV series
featured The Syndicate as a recurring
criminal organization however I suspect
the film franchise will want to move on
to a different villain the other villain
whose future seems over is Henry cavils
Walker after all he did fall off a cliff
after a huge hook smashed into his
already burned face however we never saw
the body and crazy things have happened
to bring back seemingly dead villains in
the movies even if there's a small
chance he's still alive I really don't
think we'll see him return for the next
movie as it would feel to repeat II
though maybe he could make a surprise
cameo down the road perhaps as a
horribly disfigured criminal mastermind
so this latest Mission Impossible movie
really feels like it's making a
concerted effort to build a more closely
connected cinematic universe with
recurring villains and new characters
like eels from Bengie returning in each
film to build a bigger team it also felt
like there were more callbacks and
easter eggs to previous movies unusual
for example when Ilsa was gagged and
tied up by lain it felt like a nod to
when philip Seymour Hoffman's villain
bound and gagged Julia in the third
movie in fallout Ethan pretends to be
Locke with the hope that White Widow and
Locke have never met atactic the team
previously used in Ghost Protocol this
time Henry calves Walker mocks the plan
saying hope isn't a strategy the scene
where Luthor Ethan and Benji set up an
elaborate fake hospital room and TV show
so the nuclear scientists will reveal
his phone's passcode reminded me of the
fake-out opening scene in the first
movie where the team used a similar scam
to extract crucial details from an
adversary and the final scene of Ethan
climbing up a rock face after his fight
with Walker to be rescued by a
helicopter calls back to the beginning
of Mission Impossible - where Ethan's
rock climbing vacations interrupted by
an IMF helicopter so what did you think
of
impossible six and did it get you
excited for the future of the franchise
and were there any other interesting
connections you spotted let me know in
the comments below if you enjoyed this
video I really appreciate a thumbs up or
a share tapleft for my other Mission
Impossible videos or tap write for
another video you're sure to like thanks
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers